it's a good question i think try to do
good by other people we have a lot of
problems i have lived an incredibly
privileged life I've been fortunate to
grow up in America I've been fortunate
to get the best the American educational
system has both in terms of the best
primary school the best high school
fantastic college in a fantastic medical
school and I've been fortunate enough to
have a pretty good life you know the
ability to give back and the ability to
make a positive sustained difference to
people is what I try to do both in the
United States and other countries where
I go
i don't think i have a real role model
in that sense there are a number of
people and again I've been incredibly
fortunate at meeting a number of great
people great doctors great economist
great philosophers great scientific
researchers who've been just wonderful
people and many things and wonderful
people in part because they've taken the
time to talk to me and to help me and to
set me right I is any one of them more
inspiring I don't think so but I do I
mean when I think of the number just the
sheer number of brilliant people that
I've been able to interact with it's
been phenomenal and I've real again I
can't say enough I've been very
privileged in you know when you go to a
great college in the United States when
you go to a great University in medical
school when you travel the world you do
meet lots of really smart people and you
just learn a lot from them and I'd also
say you know there's a number of high
school teachers who were just wonderful
you know just taught their heart out and
not just to me but to my classmates and
that in some ways is you know to make
you love learning and to make you want
to learn and want to excel that's pretty
you know that gives you lifelong skills
well for me since I deal with values
that's the sort of political philosophy
part I deal with public values values
that have to be shared among very many
Americans and it we try to approach use
our understanding of values in
relationship to scientific questions so
that's the relationship I am not the
only person but I think they're only two
of us in the country who have trained
both in political philosophy and in
medicine